when you guys were starting the band you
guys were originally Wicked Lester which
I think is a great name by the way and
then you wanted to name the band [__] we
were talking about it let's call let's
call about first record could be it
okay it could be you but you but it
wasn't serious all of us were riding in
my car I think it was a Plymouth or a
Dodge polara and we were throwing around
names and I thought to myself oh Jesus
this is the name dear God let's not turn
this into it you know an ego fight and I
said you ready kiss and everybody went
yeah so to me kiss was a word that
transcended the English language you
could go almost anywhere in the world
and say the word kiss and people would
go oh I've heard of them it's like
calling a band water and a kiss of death
a kiss of passion it just seemed to
incorporate all the elements of what we
were doing the letters didn't stand for
anything
we're smart but we're not that smart
right you know because the fans think
that do you guys when I say own the name
kiss in other words if I put out a
product that said um uh kiss bed sheets
because I like the word I couldn't right
no but we can make a deal we can make a
deal
foreign